c'est un matin comme les autres vous
allumez votre pc et là vous découvrez
horrifié que vous n'avez plus accès à
rien votre compte bancaire a été vidée
vos photos intimes dévoilé et des
insultes ont été envoyés à tous vos
contacts votre imprimante se met soudain
en marche
imprimant un message qui vous glacent le
sang est ce qu'une telle situation est
encore possible en 2020 tout est censé
être plus sécurisé on est plus sur
windows 98 tout on avait peur de cliquer
sur un simple lien internet
aujourd'hui il y à des mises à jour des
antivirus des autorisations des double
authentification et cetera
or en 2020 il est encore possible de se
faire pirater son ordinateur depuis les
années 2000 et même 2010 les stratagèmes
et les technologies ont beaucoup évolué
et pesons le point ensemble
attention cette vidéo n'est en aucun cas
un tutoriel de hacking c'est de la
prévention que nous réalisons avec mort
dpn qui notre partenaire sur cette vidéo
vous montrera que des choses que vous
pensez sécurisé au top de la technologie
ne le sont pas toujours
notons encore acquis un mot de passe par
force brute en 2010 est le parlement
britannique est en panique 90 comptes de
messagerie de députés ont été piratés
même le compte de la première ministre
theresa may est compromis par cette
attaque informatique
est-ce que les hackers ont utilisé des
failles informatiques extrêmement
complexe pour arriver à un tel niveau
dans l'appareil d'état britannique non
ils ont juste utiliser une attaque de
type brute force le principe est ultra
bourrin vous tester des millions de mots
de passe
un par un et vous espérez que ça marche
à la préhistoire du hacking c'était long
et fastidieux mais avec la montée en
puissance des machines c'est devenu
beaucoup plus simple avec 25 cartes
graphiques il ne faudrait que 5h30 pour
tester toutes les combinaisons d'un seul
mot de passe ça va même encore plus vite
quand vous utilisez un dictionnaire au
lieu de tester toutes les combinaisons
possibles vous tester les combinaisons
probable en gros des mots de passe
souvent utilisés vous vous pensez
sûrement unique
ahmed dragon un prix de 16 666 ou
football 2000 en mots de passe pourtant
vous faites partie du top 1000 des plus
fréquemment utilisés et cette négligence
c'est pas seulement ton petit cousin
avec de thuy non non ça touche même les
plus gros le code du lancement des
missiles nucléaires américains étaient 8
0 pendant 15 ans le mot de passe admin 2
facebook pour se connecter à n'importe
quel profil était jacques noris mouais
le texas rangers je mets les pieds
pareil pour hotmail en 1999 n'importe
quel compte et est accessible en tapant
est mais ça c'est vieux n'est-ce pas une
époque révolue non pas vraiment il ya
quelques jours un expert en sécurité
auraient réussi à se connecter au
twitter de donald trump son code aurait
été mag à 2020 magas c'était beau mais
camélia great games ça paraît un peu
gros certains doutent mais ce genre de
négligence s'est déjà vu car tester des
centaines de mots de passe est une
technique qui marche c'est encore
massivement utilisés par les hackers
à travers le monde on décompte plus d'un
million d' attaque brute force chaque
heure des attaques maintenant accessible
au commun des mortels par des logiciels
comme h cat ou jack de reaper forcément
en face la défense organisme nous
n'allez pas brute force un mot de passe
d'un compte google avec votre simple
petit pc après est ce vraiment
impossible
rien n'arrête un braqueur premières
lignes de dépenses en ti brute force
les quatre chars il s'agit d'un test qui
permet de savoir si vous êtes un humain
ou un robot
il s'agit de résoudre des puzzles de
reconnaître une séquence de lettres
déformés ou bien de trouver un objet
dans une photo découpée
est ce qu'une machine est incapable de
résoudre ça non tout est possible avec
les intelligences artificielles
c'est même déjà accessible au grand
public regardez je télécharge ça je
teste et le logiciel arrive à le
résoudre
c'est pour ça que depuis 2007 on passe
sur une nouvelle génération de cap chat
et ce n'est pas des castes est encore
plus difficile à résoudre
non juste une simple case à cocher ici
l'algorithme analyse les micro
mouvements de votre souris et détermine
si vous êtes humains un robot aura des
mouvements trop mécanique trop répétitif
et se fera immédiatement cramer enfin ça
c'est en théorie parce que des mecs ont
réussi à trouver des mouvements de
souris robotique qui passent le cap chat
et pour les tests de reconnaissance
d'objets il suffit de dire qu'on est
aveugle et google nous fait passer un
test audio qui pour un bot est beaucoup
plus facile à résoudre
les catcheurs n'empêche rien ils ne font
que ralentir et les hackers ont toujours
gagné cette bière et même si un jour un
captcha venais vraiment être un
crackable pas de souci on peut revenir
au bon vieux humains des personnes
payées 1 dollars les 1000 cap chat dans
d'immenses pharma-quick deuxième ligne
de défense anti bruteforce bloquer les
ordinateurs qui font trop de tentatives
brute force et une adresse gmail c'est
possible mais là il faudra être prêt
très mais alors très patient parce que
vous avez le droit qu'à trois tentatives
toutes les six heures avant que votre
compte soit ralenti ou carrément bloqué
et ça avec une seule adresse ip bien
qu'avec un mot de passe de huit
caractères avec que des chiffres comme
votre date de naissance ça
andré dix mille ans l'astuce des hackers
ici c'est de faire chaque tentative
depuis une ip différente
bon faudrait quand même des millions
d'années pour un mot de passe complexe
c'est plus pour tester et tenter de
réduire la liste troisième ligne de
défense anti brute de force
la double authentification voilà
imaginons que le bruit de force un
marché le mec accède à votre compte et
là la dernière chose qui va vous sauver
c'est la double authentification
ça peut être un deuxième code à rentrer
une clé usb cryptée insérer ou plus
communément un sms à valider et ça à
moins qu on vous vole votre portable
aucune chance qu'un hacker pas ça vous y
croyez vraiment il n'ya rien qu'un
hacker ne puisse pas passer
bon par contre c'est un peu technique
c'est notamment arrivé au fameux
youtuber linus technip spécialiste en
technologie ouais c'est cocasse mais
vous allez voir en même temps séditieux
le hacker a appelé l'opérateur téléphone
de linus s'est fait passer pour lui et a
réussi à convaincre l'opérateur de
rediriger tous les appels et les sms de
la cime de linus vers la sienne ouais
c'est possible de faire ça et plusieurs
youtuber on a été victime comme bullet
in a été tiède ou est stricte et même si
vous n'arrivez pas à convaincre
l'opérateur vous pouvez utiliser cet
appareil un nid et messi catcheur fausse
antennes relais oui comme dans les films
ce relais va vous permettre
d'intercepter les communications
téléphoniques et donc le sms de
validation cet appareil n'est même plus
nécessaire aujourd'hui puisque la chaîne
radio-canada a montré comment avec une
attaque s est il était possible
d'intercepter à distance des
communications ainsi en 2010 est en
allemagne des dizaines de comptes
bancaires ont été vidés avec des hackers
qui n'était peut-être même pas dans
ladite une troisième méthode encore plus
folle a été montré par le youtube heures
et à coeur kevin mitnick il envoie une
fausse invitation linkedin par mail le
lien ressemble en tous points l'officiel
mais il ne l'est pas ce qui est fou
c'est que le site fonctionne vous pouvez
vous loguez et accéder à votre session
mais derrière le hacker récupérer votre
cookies de session de double
authentification et pourra ainsi se
connecter un outil comme beijing a rendu
ces types d'attaqués grand public
vérifiez toujours que l'url soit la
bonne avant d'entrer votre mot de passe
ça peut parfois être technique avec des
adresses à rallonge heureusement vous
n'avez pas peur de ça vous êtes prudent
votre mot de passe est solide et de là à
ce qu'un hacker le des chiffres
est-ce que vous en êtes si su comment
casser un chiffrage moderne de mot de
passe
avez vous déjà taper votre email sur
travail bit aw
si oui il y a de grandes chances que
vous découvre
que votre mot de passe hollande lui
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'un
hacker a trouvé une faille sur un site
où vous êtes inscrit la télécharger
toute la base de données et donc votre
mot de passe avec seulement ce n'est pas
si simple
les mots de passe ne sont quasi jamais
enregistrées directement tel quel ils
sont chiffrés dans la base de données
votre mot de passe princess est devenu
ceci on appelle ça un h une fonction
mathématique qui va transformer un mot
en une suite de caractères
indéchiffrable quand vous vous connectez
c'est une comparaison entre le h de ce
que vous venez de taper et celui déjà
inscrit votre mot de passe n'apparaît
jamais en clair mais ce n'est pas
forcément un souci pour le hacker vous
souvenez des dictionnaires de mot de
passe souvent utiliser il suffit de tous
les chiffres et en h et comparer avec ce
qu'on a trouvé dans la base de données
c'est aussi simple que ça les hackers ne
s'amuse pas à déchiffrer tous les mots
de passe
un parent seulement les plus simples
sont liker et vu que 66% des internautes
n'utilisent qu'un ou deux mots de passe
pour tous leurs comptes en ligne
une fois qu'on a trouvé que tu utilises
et princess 2000 pour ton facebook
il y a de grandes chances que ce soit
aussi le cas sur steam août au compte
bancaire c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
les sites ajoute un salt c'est-à-dire un
deuxième niveau de cryptage propre site
qui fait que chaque h est vraiment
unique
les dictionnaires sont rendus inutiles
reste craquer de tels h n'est pas
impossible du moins si vous avez un
super ordinateur de l'armée et que le
mot de passe ne soit pas trop compliqué
prenez un mot de passe près simple
seulement des lettres minuscules s'il
fait du caractère ça prendra une minute
s'il en fait 10 un an s'il en fait 12 8
mille cinq cents ans il en fait 16
plusieurs milliards d'années
imaginez maintenant qu'on a joué les
chiffres des majuscules et des
caractères spéciaux non en vrai ça va
les âges sont sécurisés même avec
l'émergence d'un ordinateur quantique
dont la puissance de calcul est juste
terrifiante si votre mot de passe est
suffisamment complexe ya peu de chances
que ça pose un jour un problème trouver
votre mot de passe en utilisant vos vi
c'est une histoire d'horreur qui est
arrivé à plusieurs youtuber vous recevez
un mail pour une opé spé le mec paye
bien le produit a l'air cool il ya un
site professionnel donc vous téléchargez
le logiciel ou le jeu dont vous devez
faire la promotion vous l'ouvrez hélas
rien l'entreprise dit juste que c'est un
bug qui vont le régler sauf que le
hacker vient d'injecter intro jeanne il
peut récupérer tous les mots de passe et
cookies de session de votre ordinateur
avec un keylogger il peut voir tout ce
que vous écrivez sur votre clavier
le but volé votre chaîne youtube davy
mourier a raconté cette histoire qui est
arrivé à certains de ses amis youtuber
un faux mail de pixel games et quelques
heures plus tard leur chaîne youtube
était vide est devenue une chaîne de
tutos bitcoin pour les indiens parfois
pas besoin d'eux
salut de virus par exemple vous recevez
un mail de votre patron avec un lien
vers l'intranet vous fait confiance vous
entrez votre mot de passe et vous venez
de vous faire hacker l'accès à toutes
les bases clients et les futurs projets
de l'entreprise car ce n'était pas
vraiment votre patron et le site de
l'entreprise n'était qu'une limitation
c'est arrivé à equifax la plus grosse
société d'évaluation de crédit du monde
le coût de cette attaque plus de 700
millions de dollars rien que pour
rembourser ses clients et réparer la
brèche en 2017 le ministère des finances
a voulu tester ses 145 mille
fonctionnaires en leur envoyant des
mails piégée il aura fallu moins de deux
heures pour que trente mille d'entre eux
répondent à ses mails la sécurité de
l'état n'est clairement pas assurée mais
même en faisant attention vous pouvez
être piégé par exemple dans les fichiers
word de candidature vous lisez le cv
d'un candidat sauf qu'il y avait un
virus intégré
c'est comme ça qu'a essayé d'être
recruté michael owen les recruteurs ont
ouvert son fichier et ont installé un
virus qui a imprimé sur toutes les
imprimantes de la boîte trouvé moins un
travail où je supprime tous les dossiers
de votre disque dur pas certain que cela
soit la bonne méthode
cette méthode est appelée ingénierie
sociale utilisez vos avis vos faiblesses
humaines pour récupérer vos accès toi
qui pensent à être l'heureux gagnant
tiré au hasard pour recevoir un ipad
c'est l'appât du gain dans le cas d'un
fossile des impôts qui vous demande de
régler vos impayés en urgence sous peine
de vous envoyer les us y est belle le
hacker joue sur votre coire 10 dans le
cas d'un pop-up de sites pour adultes
qui fait semblant de bloquer votre pc et
vous demande de donner vos accès c'est
la culpabilité qui exploite et enfin
vous êtes un soldat américain vous
trouver une clé usb au sol en plein
moyen orient est ce que ça appartient à
l'ennemi à moins que ce soit le vestige
d'une vie détruite curiosité malsaine
vous souhaitez savoir ce qu'elle
contient vous le branchez sur
l'ordinateur de l'armée et boum
vous avez infecté tout le réseau des
milliers de données militaires ont été
envoyés a honte c'est qu'ils ont de 16
ou une attaque bien réel qui a été
qualifié par le secrétaire à la défense
de brèches la plus importante de
l'histoire des états unis
ici le danger c'est votre curiosité
enfin le dernier vis ça sera votre
crédulité votre gentillesse
ne laissez jamais personne accéder à
votre pc sans surveillance vos mots de
passe sont stockés vous pouvez même les
lire depuis les paramètres de google
chrome
un pc c'est personnel et on ne le
partage pas votre plus grand ennemi ce
n'est pas le hacker c'est vous même
comment les hackers réussissent à
récupérer les mots de passe sur vos
téléphones toute notre vie et dans nos
téléphones
on l'a en permanence à côté de soi ou
dans sa poche il est là sous contrôle et
on a cette fausse idée de sécurité des
applications se téléchargent sur des
store ultra contrôlé les mises à jour
sont fréquentes et le code pin bloc le
téléphone au bout de trois tentatives
pourquoi devrait-on train de les hackers
première faille les empreintes digitales
en récupérant une trace que vous avez
laissé sur une canette ou même un écran
de téléphone des chercheurs de
l'université du michigan ont été
capables d'imprimer une main en 3d qui
peut déverrouiller votre téléphone
deuxième file et câble de recharge un
pote vous prête un câble vous le
branchez et vos données sont aspirés
c'était un câble omg vous avez été
victime d'un biting troisième faille le
faith heidi une simple photo peut
déverrouiller un téléphone de mauvaise
qualité
mais pour l'iphone impossible de le
berner même avec un masque le faith
heidi analyse 30000 paramètres sur les
reliefs de votre visage pour déterminer
si vous êtes bien vous est bien vivant
sauf que ces paramètres
les hackers les connaissent tous au
point de pouvoir reproduire un masque
débrouille effectivement votre téléphone
plus simplement ils peuvent
déverrouiller pendant que vous êtes
endormi
normalement c'est impossible faut avoir
les yeux ouverts c'est une sécurité pour
éviter qu'un escroc vous endorment et
vous volent mais on a trouvé qu'avec une
simple paire de lunettes avec un carré
blanc ça suffit pour simuler la lueur
d'un oeil et faire croire à l'iphone que
vous êtes réveillé je ne parle même pas
du hacker starbucks qui a réussi à
passer la reconnaissance de l'iris
vous savez comme dans les films il l'a
fait depuis nos photos infrarouges sur
laquelle est placée une lentille de
contact par dessus le jour ça sera
possible de fabriquer un masque 3d à
partir d'une simple photo
faith heidi aura des gros soucis à se
faire 4e faille le wifi les méthodes
pour accéder à ta connexion wifi
mériterait une vidéo entière en soi
quand tu es en wifi ce sont des ondes
qui contiennent toutes tes données tant
historique la carte bancaire et ton mot
de passe tout ça c'est possible de les
intercepter
évidemment ces chiffres et mais si on a
accès à ta box ça l'est déjà beaucoup
moins les hackers trouve constamment de
nouvelles failles ça va être des failles
techniques mais surtout humaine deux
fosses pop up qui te demande de te
reconnecter à ta box ou des wifi publics
gratuits piéger une histoire assez
terrifiante a fait beaucoup de bruit en
2016 c'est celle du journaliste stephen
pitrau il était dans un avion connecté
au wifi et il écrivait un article
brûlant sur le fbi et ses relations avec
apple le genre d'article qui va faire du
bruit
l'atterrissage surprise un noble
approche et lui dit j'ai hacké louhichi
j'ai lu tous tes mails à propos du lait
bio tu devrais peut-être faire attention
à ce que tu écris sur un wifi public
c'est digne d'un grand film d'espionnage
et si bien que certains doutent
est-ce que ce n'était pas un réseau wifi
piégé dans l'avion à moins qu'ils aient
simplement regarder au dessus de son
épaule car aujourd'hui
les wi fi publics de grands groupes sont
mieux sécuriser vos données sont
absolument illisible et vous pouvez vous
connecter à mcdonald's sans problème à
condition quand même de vérifier que
c'est bien le vrai oui si de mcdonald's
et que vous êtes sur des sites https
chez vous veillez à toujours avoir des
mots de passe très long même si c'est
relou à entrer au lycée en 2020 est bien
sécurisée mais ça reste toujours une
faille 5e failli vous même car votre
sentiment de sécurité peut vous jouer
des tours imaginez le portable de votre
ami est posée juste à côté de vous vous
tapez votre mot de passe sur un clavier
et là comme par magie
vous venez de donner vos accès comment
at il fait il a simplement écouter le
bruit de vos claviers car oui chaque
touche ne fait pas le même bruit la
distance de quelques millièmes de
secondes entre les touches peut
s'entendre
aujourd'hui on est capable de
reconnaître 41% des caractères et avec
un peu d'intelligence artificielle
prédictive on peut carrément savoir ce
que vous écrivez
si ça vous semble bien futuriste dites
vous qu'il ya plus invraisemblable car
aujourd'hui un simple téléphone est
capable de voir à travers les murs
plusieurs youtuber en font la
démonstration
et après tout est ce vraiment étonnant
les scanner d'aéroport ça bien voir à
travers votre valise murs ne sont une
limite que pour la lumière mais d'autres
ondes peuvent les traversées et pourquoi
pas plus tard voir les mouvements de vos
doigts sur un clavier par vos voisins du
dessus ce n'est pas de la science
fiction
alors pourquoi je vous raconte tout ça
pas pour vous aider à hacker pas pour
vous faire peur mais pour vous éduquer à
la sécurité c'est ce que nous a demandé
de faire notre sponsor très impliqué
dans les questions de sécurité
norvégienne
alors oui mort vpn ça permet d'accéder à
des netflix en dehors de la france
oui ça vous permet de changer de pays
pour vous cacher mais un vpn ça sert pas
qu'à ça il y a aussi des questions de
sécurité avec un vpn toutes vos données
passent par un filtre un serveur qui va
anonymisées et sécuriser votre
navigation un chiffrage puissant de tous
vos flux de données pour que personne
les interceptent des bloqueurs de
publicité et de malwares qui empêche à
coeur et gouvernement de vous intercepté
des mots de passe chiffrés avec les plus
puissants algorithmes et bien sûr une
garantie qu'aucune de vos données ne
seront gardés par la société north dpn
et recommandé par plein de spécialistes
est qu est même élu meilleur vpn 2019 et
2020 par l'un des experts du milieu
j'ai des codes de réduction bien sûr -
68% sur north bay pn 3,15 euros par mois
et en bonus avec un mois supplémentaire
gratuit c'est sur notre lien en
descriptions avec le code promo sur
strache merci pour le soutien après
cette vidéo vous savez comment on n'a
qu'un mot de passe en 2020 mais à quoi
ça ressemblerait en 2040
peut-être pas si différent
qu'aujourd'hui même avec l'introduction
des ordinateurs quantiques
car même si on l'a vu la technologie des
hackers évolue constamment
elle qui défendent aussi c'est une
course sans fin l'important est de
rester à jour
c'est devenu un enjeu de sécurité
nationale car se joue aujourd'hui une
guerre entre les états une guerre sans
mort certes mais qui peut faire de gros
dégâts derrière les hackers il n'y a pas
que des petits génies dans leur chambre
il y a aussi des gouvernements des
gouvernements qui utilise la terreur et
le pillage des citoyens pour affaiblir
leurs ennemis ainsi récemment certains
virus semble affecter que les
ordinateurs des adversaires de la russie
et parmi eux ceux des alliés quelle
coïncidence
je vous rassure en face les américains
ne sont pas des tendres non plus
finalement internet c'est comme l'amour
faut rester protégé j'espère que vous
avez appris deux trois petites choses
que vous avez aimé cette vidéo à grand
merci à luz m h 13 et marquent nos
acteurs spécialistes sur cette vidéo
pourrait aussi demander à courrier sache
mais bon il est en prison
merci aussi à match le kent pour son
aide sur cette vidéo les monteurs boa
goa antho eacu fise pour le montage
n'hésitez pas à nous suivre sur twitter
si ça vous a plu faites le nous savoir
commentaire c'était matar chaud
[Musique]